this whole cult thing I don't get it
Sedona is a weird one right because it's
all like crystals and healers it's all
people looking to be spiritual they've
given up on on traditional religion but
they seem to need that sort of vibe yeah
and so they get into like spiritual
stuff and channelers and healers have
you got it in that I knew it all day
long are you channeling broke yeah no no
I think we I really do believe and I've
been believing this more and more lately
though that our understanding of what
our memory is is very limited and that
the reason why people are scared of
things some things is probably because
there's some sort of genetic memory of
someone that they knew like I bet your
kid will have somehow or another that
knowledge of that motorcycle accident
and that fee there's I think Shinda that
goes through DNA really yeah I do I
think that's why kids are scared of
monsters you know why is kids scared of
monsters why are they scared of bullets
or fires or you know why Thirsk you mean
they're scared of something that I was
scared I've grown up no there's animals
used to eat people yeah that's what I
think
I think monsters represent like Jaguars
and shit are you going through the
jungle try to get some water and you get
jacked
that's our ancestors all of our
ancestors every single human being on
this planet came from Africa all of us
100% of us everyone Absolution black
white all of us got eaten all of our
answers so get our DNA it's wired
there's cats out there yeah what are you
afraid of monsters in the dark
those are cats man we got jacked by cats
like all the time yeah yeah so that's
why everybody scared of things under the
bed what's in the closet they're hiding
their cats big cats looking to get you I
don't know about that this is very scary
for a moment but I don't believe in that
why do you think that animals have
instincts right look here's a perfect
example we have instincts right but what
kind of instincts
have weird instincts like they all sniff
each other's assholes yeah they all piss
on spots where other animals did they
don't nobody had to teach my dog how to
do that my dog I got him when he was six
weeks old and I've had him for two and a
half years that motherfucker will sniff
something and he see somebody peed on it
he pees on it but he learned that from
his learn from nobody no he learned that
from his dog people like him over here
he didn't know jack shit so no I think
it's in his DNA okay yeah I get that but
what is the DNA like doesn't your DNA
carry some traces of information on to
your own children like what I notice in
my children okay they share certain
weird traits that I have that I don't
fit like like obsessive-compulsive
traits that I don't think they see
because I don't really bring that home
like especially the workout stuff and
like some things that I really get kind
of psychotic about martial arts stuff my
my middle daughter has that in a crazy
way and I'm like oh okay this is me if I
was a girl
okay like if I was a little girl this is
me like what is this my memory that's in
her or is it do I have like some weird
obsessive gene which it is because I see
my son he's only two he just turned 2
but he makes facial expressions and
looks like he does certain looks that I
do and my wife goes he's acting like you
right now do you think he's act like you
because he sees you act like that
because he knows in his head that that's
how he's wired like that because when I
watch it he doesn't not like a lot of
this stuff he does I'd only I don't even
do he just does like my mom I'll come
over and show watch him she go you know
he's just like you when you were this
age and it's so weird yeah it's in the
DNA it's in something right whatever it
is whether it's in cellular memory DNA
some sort of genetic information gets
passed on but the parents to the child
you could say that about athletics
though like if you know that's a little
different though but it's in the DNA
yeah it isn't but it's not an ethereal
thing like a thought